my yesterday is an ex-murder detective
he's been doing uh doing this for the
last 30 years at essex police force and
he's experienced everything whether it's
investigating countless criminal cases
horrific murders he kept i mean a lot of
different things he's seen and i saw a
couple of his interviews and his
expertise is interviewing the person
that's being committed of the murder or
the crime to gather intel to see if this
person's guilty or innocence or he needs
to go gather more intel and i think
there's a lot of uh we can learn from
that in any career you're in maybe even
your personal life so having said that
paul mallory thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment
[Music]
so question for you when did you wake up
and say i want to be a murder detective
well i come from a line of cops my dad
was a cop my brother was a cop
my uncles my cousins we're cops you know
that's if you we have the most boring
christmas dinners in the world
um
what's it look like what do you guys do
tell stories to each other oh man it's
so boring as well you know
we call it swinging the blue lamp in
this country and um
and and everybody knows everyone you
know i live in a county which is
different to the states there's 1.7
million people live here and we're next
to london
so the demographics are really um you
know very very diverse however within
the police service you've got 3 000 cops
plus support staff
and everyone knows everyone so my dad
knew people when i first joined the
police in 86 87 i was working with cops
that my dad had joined with so i
couldn't do anything
without them now so as an example march
31st 1989 my first major investigation
and i'll come back to when did i want to
be a mere but my first major
investigation a bank manager have been
kidnapped
um i just got onto a plane closed
department as a
an assistant a temporary detective
and this bank manager's been kidnapped
his family been kidnapped and he's been
taken to a bank to empty the vault and i
walk into the office and the boss sits
there and he says um
mr malaria so i said yes sir he said no
your father i said yeah yeah yeah you do
said them
can you cook i said yeah i can cook he
said you want to be on my team so yeah i
want to be honest he said well then you
can cook me breakfast for the whole team
tomorrow so i had to cook
big english breakfast you know sausage
egg bacon beans
for the whole
that was part of my acceptance and there
was 25 people there or thereabouts
and i knew then to be part of a
professional team because
to be on a murder squad it's not about
one person you watch all the
glorification of
how somebody solved the murder you know
this isn't um
1890s this isn't jack the ripper this
isn't sherlock holmes this is one team
but a team that's made up of so many
different people i don't know how that
correlates in the us but you can't do
these things on your own in the uk
and i knew from that point on was that
all i wanted to do with deal with was
major crime that was that was my life
now let me ask you this so yesterday i'm
interviewing uh a former um
sniper he had the longest shot and i
think he's from britain by the way his
name was craig harrison i believe right
yesterday's interview craig harrison
and uh he had 80 confirmed kills
and i have interviewed other snipers
before and i was in the military before
so i've met snipers and they typically
have a very similar dna they're loners
they're good being by themselves they're
a little bit quiet
some people think they're shy but
they're very observant of what's going
on around them so you can pretty much
you know
map out the patterns and the
similarities between different between
10 different snipers right
did you notice a pattern with folks who
are
great murder detectives what what what
qua what the similarities do you guys
have
i think um
if you've got an analytical mind and the
ability to talk to people
then you can
you can then start to fit in but the
you have to look at the the minute
detail you have to understand what
actually matters you have to have
um
a passion for knowledge and that's what
the common denominator is for
murder squad detectives certainly in the
uk i've worked with some of the finest
um
and i don't want to be blowing up their
backsides but you know some of the
finest detectives in the in the country
and i've been privileged to do that and
i've done some great jobs and but we all
come from the same
cut from the same cloth but the fact is
the reason we we did it or do it or the
you know the reason why they're still
doing it is because
they want to find out why that person's
been killed why they want to bring the
right person to justice they want to
understand
how we've got into this situation where
there's a body in the mortuary and a
postmortem is going to take place they
want to bring the closure about for the
family and this is what it's all about
it's about
the focus on the family and how they
can be dealt with and the service that
they provide and i i think that that's
the biggest asset i want to go a little
bit deeper i mean i appreciate that but
i want to go a little bit deeper this is
what i think and and correct me and say
no that's irrelevant and if yes tell me
which one of these is the most valuable
asset in your world in your industry so
the importance of
uh of
gathering intel which is researching to
me you're good at researching so when
you're sitting down with somebody you've
asked all the right questions from the
right people you have intel number two
is human nature knowing how to deal with
the person you're talking to where you
lead to being trusting
and somewhat understanding maybe a
little bit of levity to bring the guards
down where they're willing to sit down
and talk to you
maybe
a bit of humility where you're not too
cocky and arrogant because they shut
down when you're too cocky and arrogant
and you're pushing them too hard which
one of those like i want to know things
like that what's the most valuable
quality of the best person in your field
the ability to communicate but
communication is a two-way thing it's as
well as well as using this it's about
using these so it's about talking and
listening
and being able to
glean information as you go along and be
dynamic in the way that you
you work
you can't always there's no prescription
around um or a menu around dealing with
murders
that said there is a guidebook which
it literally starts at point a and point
and goes through to point zed
but you have to be a free thinker but
you have to have that ability to
communicate and engage
because if you can't engage with the
suspect with the families
um
with the uh we have here you have a da's
office we have the crown prosecution
service if you can't engage whether that
be in an oral way or whether it be in a
written way
you're not going to succeed and you've
got no place in you know in that
particular job because you need to be
able to do that
at the lowest and at the highest level
because you will be dealing
with
the lower end of society with in some
cases but you'll also be going to the
upper end of the market when you're
dealing with
some families the judges i mean the
judges are very well esteemed in this
country in the same way they are there
they're not voted in here
um
but
you know that you've got to be able to
communicate and that's the greatest
skill that
murder squad detectives have let's let's
let's let's uh you know unpack that so
you're saying the lower end of society
so to be able to communicate with the
lower end of society give us a few uh
approaches you got to take that works
and what doesn't work in communicating
with the lower end of society because
i'm assuming these murderers
they don't have to really talk to you
right they don't have to tell you
anything right
do they have to tell you anything you
have to figure out where to gather them
from them right
but you see social deprivation is you
know it's right in your country is right
for our country
so for instance you you've got an area
that's particularly poor
somebody gets killed and the residents
do not want to engage they don't engage
because they're seen as being police
informants
it's about that the communication to
bring them along with you and give them
the appropriate reassurance that they're
going to get that support now some
people we have a witness protection
scheme here same as you do in the
u.s some people need to go on that but
actually it's around that community
liaison and making sure that you're
getting the
the right vibes across to the the
community leaders if you like and i
think that that's and that's
particularly difficult at the moment in
this country with some of the um some of
the popular press the police are getting
a really good figuratively speaking but
they're getting a good kick at the
moment from the media and it's about um
offering that public reassurance and
that customer focus so but that goes
right across the board so it could be
you know kids died of a drug overdose
they come from a poor background it's
about making sure that parents get the
best service because people should not
be written off just because where they
come from or whatever
status
you know but popular society would write
a lot of people off and that is totally
out of order that's so wrong but the
police i think they're very skilled in
it despite what is said by a lot of the
media they're very skilled in in what
they do
so so going back to it lower end of
society when you're dealing with the
lower end of society
and specifically let's focus on a person
that is being accused charged with a
murder okay and that if you're speaking
to somebody
who
potentially just took someone's life
and
they're qualified to be part of the
lower end of society
what method of communication works with
them and what doesn't
so
it's very difficult because in this
country in the same way as the states
they have the rights of silence so to
engage with somebody when they're
sitting across the table they've just
killed somebody
we've dealt with a guy called justin
chan he was the victim of a murder um
he'd been bullied he'd been harangued
he'd gone through so many different
things
you weren't ever going to negotiate with
with his killer
there wasn't a chance he wasn't you had
to prove that 100 because
he wasn't ever going to talk to us he
you know he can make maintain his right
silence and
and the police have to pray and the
police should have to prove it as well
in the same way as anything that you
know it should be in this country in the
same air it's beyond reasonable doubt
you can't negotiate with someone like
that
but there are other people that you
dealt that i've dealt with where
actually they've got a conscience as to
what they've done they've killed a
partner so
i can't
defend what they've done i can empathize
through the situation they've gone
through so let me ask you a question now
what do adults argue about
as as couples what do i adults argue
about i'll tell you money family kids
sex exactly okay exactly so when you're
sitting across the table from somebody
who has killed their husband because
every night they've demanded
rough specs with them beating them about
that they've knocked the kids about
you can't sympathize with them but you
can actually understand where they're
coming from and if you can get that
across and start to
start to help them with the process
because they're going to jail make no
mistake and it could be that they go to
jail for murder they go to jail for
manslaughter as it is in this country
if you can start to empathize and start
to unpack what they've done then that
gives them a greater opportunity the
lawyers
wouldn't agree the lawyers are there to
make them you know no comment no comment
no comment they're not going to talk to
us but it's about the questions set and
the way that we prepared ourselves in
order to interview them
and
that's that's what you need what's your
open-ended so so walk me through one
give me a story and walk me through what
you opened up with what question did you
so give me the setting i'm sitting down
with this guy who's being accused of xyz
he's this age he's this he's that and
here's how the conversation started
about give me an example so danielle
jones she's still missing she went
missing in june 2001 her body has never
been found okay her uncle has been
subsequently convicted and he's still in
jail he's been there 20 years won't tell
anybody where that murder is
i was selected to interview him uh with
a colleague
and
the opening gambit was
basically
this is your niece
stuart this is your name
why
tell us what's happened and you start to
build into the relationship between him
and his niece and how you know things
gone wrong
that's that's the only way you can do it
you've got to take it from the front
what you'd actually do is you'd ask
people to explain themselves tell me
something about yourself that's how you
would start the conversation the problem
is
that not everybody can answer that
question because they just can't they
don't know i could say to you tell me
something about yourself and you tell me
your full story because you're an open
book but some people don't work like
that so you have to pick the pages apart
you have to look at each chapter of the
story how how that particular
relationship would have developed how
it's gone from one point to another
point and basically where is the body
of danielle jones and and that remains
her body's still outstanding and i i
only you know i wish to god that he'd
just tell everybody where the body is
but i'm not sure that he ever will give
me a successful one so that's an
unsuccessful one where you guys weren't
able to get
uh the information you want to give me a
story of somebody that you never thought
it was going to be
happening they were not open-minded but
you were able to get the information how
and why
right so um a lady called hannah
phillips
she was
an elderly lady and
she lived with her i believe it was a
daughter and a son-in-law
and there was a an argument in the house
she has
it turns out been pushed over banged her
head she's died
this guy
has wrapped her body up in a tarpaulin
uh a big plastic sheet taken her out
into a rural wooded area
before he actually took her there he
went and found a suitable area he dug a
hole
um
deep enough to bury the body
he wrapped up in this
tarpaulin
tied her up put her in a wheelbarrow
wheeled out to his volvo motor car
took the body out to this wooded area
and buried her now
there were there were a catalogue of
lies that were told because they
reported her as being missing
uh and so on and so forth myself and a
guy called paul thomas smashing fella uh
we were
detailed to go and arrest and interview
this chat
we go and arrest him and because he's
saying nothing i haven't done anything
wrong i haven't done anything wrong
but
and he was very very he wasn't open to
to it at all you know no no no no by the
time
we got him back into the custody suite
and we he then opened up he realized
that what had gone on
um
was wrong he needed
his conscience started to kick in and
what he actually did was he identified
where the body was buried he took us
there he put
a forensic suit on a white forensic top
to bottom forensic suit on a master
whole light he's handcuffed to us
and we took him out to where the body
was
the deposition site and the forensic
guys recovered this lady's body and he
he was subsequently convicted
uh as was his wife
and that's you know that's a that's a
success because the family would never
got the body back um
i would say it would not be because we
were good communicators that we actually
gave the body out so from the moment of
i don't want to talk to you guys to the
moment of going to showing you where the
body is how many hours or days is that
well
in this country you can only keeps on
for up to 36 hours
24 hours then a further 12 hours and
then they go into a um warranty for
detention but it wasn't a long long time
it was several hours before he actually
told us he'd obviously been playing on
his mind for some time was he was he
emotional was he crying was he in a
state of like uh yeah he was absolutely
devastated because
yeah his mother-in-law's dead and he's
got a period of body um
yeah
i mean some people will never crack and
some people will they'll tell you but
as i say the legal system in this
country
i think is a great legal system i think
you know everybody's entitled to defense
all those types of things
so so far one of so far one of the
things that i got from what you're
saying is
is if it's family
you
you negotiate with them based on
conscience
because they're feeling guilty they're
regretful that's one of the ways
yeah you try i mean
sometimes you won't negotiate because i
hated them so much that they're quite
pleased that they're they've gone um
i mean and but they're all tragic
there's no there are no good outcomes to
any of these because
somebody's died at the end of the day
someone has died and they've died at
somebody else's hand so i mean i've used
the phrase before a murder is a murder
as a murderer it's the technique that is
used in order to do that now
in the uk
our gun crime is far lower than the us
we haven't got right to bear arms
there's no second amendment is it second
amendment yeah yeah second remember you
guys have a lot of stabbing you guys got
a lot of stabbing
it corrects yeah so that that is you
know that is the um the weapon of choice
at the moment certainly within the game
culture and in some such as society
the knife and
it could be from a modeling knife
through to a bowie knife to a machete or
whatever but that is the way but the
point i make is
fortunately guns aren't as prevalent
here
so if a cop turns up to a
a job where there is a gun that's been
brandished nine times out of ten
that weapon will be illegally held
nobody will have a semi-automatic rifle
then they'll have a shotgun they'll have
a rifle for killing deer
but the fact is that most people if they
present that
and the arm police turn up they've got a
good chance getting shot because
whereas i watched a video the other day
somebody in oklahoma
running around with a with a
what he called a pistol he looked like a
rifle and he's doing a second amendment
audit and i'm thinking come on man this
is this is ridiculous we don't have that
situation here so
you know for murders where someone's
been shot yes we have them where they
have been shot we have illegally held
firearms or we'll have a shotgun that's
been sworn down so he makes a barrel
shorter easier to use
what's the most disturbing case you you
were assigned most disturbing case
and maybe the most disturbing scene
you've ever been a part of
um i think the
murder of a lady down in a place called
south end which is down on the coast
um
she'd split she came over from zimbabwe
they were they came over as medical
refugees nice family um her husband
decides he's gonna have a relationship
with another woman and
the wife isn't very happy with this
so they split up but he can't cope with
the separation so he goes to the local
army navy store um buys himself a
machete and he sits there and lovingly
hones it makes it as sharp as he
possibly can
the lady takes the children to school
and as she walks away from the school he
walks up behind her and
he severs her head with one blow takes
her head off of her shoulders with the
exception of 2.5 centimeters one inch of
skin that's holding her head on
and i think that was quite a that was
quite disturbing scene when we got to
the mortuary because
she'd been collected taken to the
mortuary and when they were preparing
for post-mortem
that was quite a disturbing sight
there are no good postmortems they're
very interesting um from a from a
biological or a medical perspective
but
none of them are particularly good
and i've been to quite a few
unfortunately what ended up happening to
that fellow from zimbabwe he got locked
up got locked up for life now that's the
difference here uh life could be up to
well you can get a full life sentence um
the police officer that's featuring so
heavily in the media at the moment um
who will remain nameless
he's just got a full life sentence and
so he should he killed that lady sarah
everyone and he deserves everything that
he gets um but
life could go from 12 years to
full life censors very few people get
full life sentences really no one goes
to the chair here got it
what do you think about the chair do you
agree with the chair or you think it's
good that you guys don't have the chair
no i think under some circumstances
i'll get shut down by some of my
colleagues but under some circumstances
yeah i don't
think that is beyond reasonable doubt if
there's dna there's never ever any
chance of it being anybody else and you
know what if you kill a cop in this
country then you face the consequences
that's my view if you've if you've um if
you're a
predatory pedophile and you've killed
children and we can prove that you've
killed them
you're no good for humanity
so if that's true that's brutal i make
no apologies no there's a lot of people
that agree with you you're not alone
there
there's there's probably a few billion
people that agree with you it's not a uh
uh a
very small percentage of the population
that would agree that wouldn't agree
with you but
let me continue on on a different route
so many of these cases you've been a
part of you know a lot of times in
movies you see the good combat cop one
guy comes in and says hey you want a
cigarette here some cigarette another
guy comes in tell me the truth hey john
get out of here let me talk to about
is that just movie stuff or did you guys
use some of those okay got it i figured
yeah good good cop bad cop can come in
many different guises because
i could be miserable anyway i don't need
to i don't need to be sitting up to the
suspect to be um
miserable or straight faced or whatever
they're not my friend
but my job my job is to get them to talk
to me okay
so
i will
i would work within the law because the
law is very clear around the way that
you obtain confessions in this country
um
and i would deal with them in a
professional way most murder suspects in
this country will have a lawyer present
there are very few that won't have legal
representation um
[Music]
some will tell you if darn it some will
tell you you know they won't i mean you
talked about talk about a disturbing one
there was um
one that really sticks in my mind
and i remember i remember more it was a
now colchester for your american um
listeners is the oldest recorded town in
great britain okay it was there for the
romans put it there and this is a local
town to us it's a it's a military base
it's where a parachute regiment are and
there's roman walls and there's roman
amphitheaters and there's all that is
it's a great place
chap was convicted of the fraud of all
things and for which he got seven years
in prison
he went to prison and whilst he was
there
he developed a toothache so they sent
him to the local hospital
in a cab okay
300 pounds 400 later
but the guy still hasn't come out from
his treatment so the taxi driver who's
obviously very bright thought oh this is
a bit strange he's not out
so
they're going to try and find him in the
meantime he's gone from one county which
is in kent
to essex on a train
he's gone to his home in colchester
where his wife was
and he stabs her to death in front of
their
baby children and i say baby they're
toddlers they're running around when we
turned up at that scene
there were blood-stained footprints
where the children had been running
through their mother's blood that is
heartbreaking
that is absolutely heartbreaking you
know what a cruel bastard and
those sorts of memories will stay with
me for the rest of my days because
it's it's when your public service kicks
in it's when you're there to work for
the victim you're there to work for the
family you're there to make sure that
justice is brought about and that person
that took that lady's life goes to
prison for a very very long time
psychologically what do those things do
to you the the do you have ever you have
flashbacks you have middle of the night
you wake up with nightmares does it do
anything like that to you because you
know many people in your world tell me
stories like that but i wonder what it
does to you
i think it makes you more look
i love life
you know
it's what we're here for isn't it and i
love my grandchildren and i love
everything you know that's wraps around
me but you become a bit of a fatalist
you understand that it's what was ansi
hopkins who said you know none of us get
out of here alive
but it's the choices that you've made or
the choices that somebody else has made
for you and do i do i have dark moments
yeah i suppose i do but i'm not i don't
hang on them
i remember i remember every postmortem
that i ever went to i remember standing
next to a lady who had taken her own
life on christmas eve
in a mortuary
and there was no viewing gallery and the
the pathologist is undertaking a
postmortem on her body
they stick with my in my mind telling
her family
that we've found the body of them their
mother you know they are the things that
stick with me forever but that's not
going to dent me as an individual
because
it's like saying i want i wanted to join
i want to go on a murder squad but i
don't want to see a dead body that just
doesn't work does it it's like saying
yeah i want to be a traffic cop but i
never want to go to a row collision no
come on do me a favor it's not going to
that's not going to happen
so you've got to be very pragmatic about
it in your approach
um but you do say look i saw a guy my
first um experience of i'd experienced
deaths before but the first guy um that
i've seen as a horrific
death
um he'd been decapitated in a row
collision he was in the road he knelt up
and as he knelt up off the road he did a
few drinks taxi came along and
took him off
took his head off here and that was that
was horrendous and i'd seen people that
jumped in front of trains and then at
five o'clock in the morning as the sun
starts to come up in you know in june
july time
the sun comes up and the birds are there
picking up these poor chaps body bits
you know that have been sprayed across
the place
they stay with you does that affect me
yeah that's times i've been in tears
i remember i was um a family people
think that
i don't know the american culture i've
got family in america and um i love
absolutely love the states but it's like
comparing apples with pears and they're
going to think i'm a soft bugger you
know that's the
but i was a family liaison officer for a
young lady and she'd been struck by a
train and it took two weeks to find her
body
and i remember getting on a plane with
my family going into spain flying down
to spain and
everybody's reading the national
newspapers and there she was on the
front page of national newspapers and we
we'd announced that we found her body
yeah they'd been all over the national
media the bbc itv the whole thing and i
just let them cry because you think
that kid's been in that
she's been dead for two weeks and we've
only just found her body so yes it does
affect you you dealt i dealt with some
lovely people from the victims
perspective
um i dealt with some really interesting
for people
i i dealt with some very interesting
suspects because they've all got a story
to tell
yeah so
let me let me ask you in in regards to
the guy that took out his wife that was
going to the dentist and the taxis like
where is he and then go find and see
what he did to his wife
did you ever interview him and speak
with him afterwards or no
i i didn't interview him okay
i was the office manager for that
particular job
but obviously i worked very closely with
the guys and girls that did do the
interviews um did you do like the reason
why i ask is you know uh kuklinskin's
story right you know the the richard
kuklinsky story do you know who he is
okay so who's the coldest
person you sat in front of where you
said this this person doesn't have a
soul did you ever sit in front of
somebody where you
maybe were
feared for your own life
um did i have a fear for my own life
not an interview no um i think the
coldest man i've ever met was stuart
campbell and he's the man who killed
danielle jones and he's the guy that's
still locked up
i
i dealt with a lady called julianne
taylor she was pretty cold she killed
her husband um stabbed him through the
heart in front of washington he was
standing by the washing machine she
stabbed him through the heart one single
stab wound she was pretty cold as well
and
i think they've all
they're all they've all got
a story i think they've all got an
element of coldness
interview one guy killed his mother
because she had alzheimer's you know and
he wasn't cold he was absolutely
distraught but there was nobody that
could deal with his mother
you know and
he put a pillow across the face
so
but i was honest i can honestly say
there's a guy called martin valentine
who i didn't interview but i worked on
the job he
shot a man by the name of john ward
and jo he shot him through the throne
and martin valentine i'd previously
dealt with
about 18 years prior to this particular
offence when he shot a security guard on
an armed robbery
he's he's pretty cold-hearted and
i would imagine he's still languishing
in a jail
do you think these guys i mean do you
psychoanalyze these guys or no your job
is just to ask questions
are used
my job is to ask questions that's it
we would be assessed by um
a psychologist for some of the jobs that
we do to make sure that we weren't um
affected by them that you know if you if
you interviewed somebody who's got a
celebrity status
um
i know i did that we had to be assessed
by a psychologist to make sure that we
were the right people so that we didn't
become starstruck who who was a
celebrity that you interviewed is this a
guy called michael barrymore he was um
he he was he was missed the saturday
night in the uk and he was accused of um
of killing somebody and that's never
been proven but yeah
did he get out did did he end up doing
time or no no no no no no he was um
there was no no case to answer against
him and in fact um sadly that the man
who's who passed away his father who's
been
champion is his cause has
recently passed away as well but yeah i
mean it's
um
it's an interesting job it's fantastic
it's it's a job that people pay money to
do because
well you look at all the all the crime
series on the television or the books
are the best you know the best books
everything um
it's all about crime is it crime and
punishment murders whatever it may be
that they are the best best series on
television it's amazing the most
interesting
yeah people are fascinated by uh
uh those stories from from the coldest
people
where you know who are who end up doing
what they do
to others murdering others
do you do you get a sense you've been in
this world for 30 years it's either
going to be a very simple no answer it's
going to be an answer with a lot of
explanation do you think these folks
some of them are born
cold the way they are
or do you think it's a life experience
situation just a lot of trauma bad
experience with parents mom dad
community you know all of the things
that they experienced or do you think
some of them are just cold from the day
they're born
they're born bad
you really believe that yeah i do
believe that i think that you know the
kid that's pulling the legs off of a
spider today who's got potential
becoming a killer in 20 years time and i
really believe that because
it's it's shown that um sex offenders
for instance they start with uh animal
cruelty cruelty um lighting small fires
things like that and then it just
escalates to
more sadistic behavior towards other
human beings and that's you know that's
well documented so i believe that i do
believe that some people are born bad i
believe that some kids are born into a
situation that
they make the wrong life choice they'll
go and commit a robbery they're nice
people in it you know
in essence they're a nice person but the
fact is they've got
life life choices they've got to commit
a robbery someone's stepped out they've
shot them they're stabbed and whatever
it may be did they go out their way to
do it i don't know i'm you know i'm not
there but i do think there are some but
i think some people are definitely born
bad how many total interviews have you
done with murderers over the 30 years
what's what's the number what do you
think
um
i think
in excess of 40
which isn't a huge amount but that's you
know it's quite a that's quite a lot how
many deaths have i been to
innumerable i mean that's i couldn't
tell you i i couldn't sit down and tell
you but yeah
so so what what have you noticed like
from from that experience what what
tales have you picked up what i mean
when i came in you were talking to david
and he said where are you from colombia
and i said be careful he's sizing you up
because he's trying to learn this if you
committed anything i'm like this guy's a
professional
question asker but
uh what have you caught any tales where
you know you say ooh that reminds me of
what the other guy did and interesting
he just got uncomfortable i must have
triggered something here have you have
you caught anything from body language
from learning by interviewing these
people
yeah i mean there is an element of that
and i think it's the way that they
answer their questions and once they
start lying because
we have to prove lies as much as we need
to find the truth you've got to prove a
lie and you i think you instinctively
know when they're telling lies certainly
if you've got but they're all
they're all
there's similarities because you've got
a dead person you've got a postmortem
but they're all so different you know
the techniques that you might use
a man by name roger turnell he he was
murdered in his home
um
gay male
traveled the world um
and
he was they set light to his house they
said they set light to his premises and
when they got into the post-mortem they
discovered that his hyoid bone had been
broken well the only way you're going to
do that is through strangulation there's
no there's no other way that that's
going to happen
we've launched a full-on murder
investigation that family were
completely different to the other
families that i've dealt with so you
can't say the issue the difficult ones
is where the suspect and you can't prove
it is a family member
and you get allocated to them and and
the family liaison in this country is
actually i don't know what it's like in
the states i know i keep saying that but
the family liaison in this country is is
a a skill on its own and you will get
placed family layers and obviously
you'll get placed with your family but
you could be sitting in a hotel room
because we've taken over the entire
house there's a crime scene you could be
sitting in the hotel room with the
suspect
and at some point you might get that
phone call from the boss to say
you've got a nick in there you've got to
arrest him or her um we think we've got
enough now to arrest him for murder or
they'll take they'll extricate you and
they'll put somebody else in to do the
arrest
30 years of doing this what have you
learned about
man what have you learned about human
beings
30 years of doing this they're evil
honestly i didn't need saving the police
to work some of that out but you know
there are some evil people out there and
we use a phrase i used earlier and are
they mad or are they bad you know and
there are some very very bad people out
there and
i don't think any of them are
trustworthy if i'm honest with you
anybody
no look
why do it
i said that's a real sweeping statement
but
when you say something oh don't say
anything and you know full well you're
feeding that in because they'll go and
tell somebody
you start to get the rub around human
nature don't you and that
most people don't do it for any bad
reason but yeah you've got it you've got
to be careful how many times have you
been married how many times have you
been married
once and you're still married to the
same person yeah yes what do you what do
you do when you're talking to your wife
and you're like babe i know you're
bullshitting me do you colorado are you
just kind of like what do you do what do
you do when that happens do you just not
say anything
she just got back she's just got back
here um
no i mean i mean you know what i'm
saying sometimes
[Laughter]
paul miller has been missing for two
weeks
yeah
you know i've got i've got two wonderful
sons but you know what i'm saying like
what i'm saying is like you know
sometimes i'm
i'm into i've been in sales for 20 years
and i've had a lot of weird people in my
life who are bipolar and personality
disorders and i've been forced to study
body language because i don't have a
choice i had to know a person who's got
seven different personalities every day
i had no idea who this person was going
to be so i'm like who are you today i'm
like okay let me pivot right but when
you when you're a parent now and you got
kids and you're married and you know
nobody walks on water when your kid lies
to you your spouse lies to you somebody
is maybe not wanting to tell you the
whole story and you know it and you read
it what do you do about it
i'm trying to keep a lid on it
it's it's
difficult the worst thing is when you
know and i still find it now i run a
business now i i run a company that um
we recruit cops
so when cops retire we recruit them into
the public or private sector we've got a
services site so people have got their
own businesses they advertise us a few
hours a few dollars a month
um
but i still get to the point when
someone says if someone walks into your
office and says you know what i've
really messed up here
you can almost forgive them you can
actually say okay as long as they tell
you true shouldn't they walk in and say
it wasn't i never did it
and that's you know your first instinct
is to go off like we have a phrase here
go up like a toughney rocket and
it's just
yeah i can explode sometimes i know you
find that hard to believe but i i have
got so i can get quite animated but
i suppose that's that's a passion yeah i
i guess the reason why i'm asking this
question is like you know uh uh to be
doing this business and you're still
married to the same how many years have
you guys been married you said grandkids
so i'm assuming okay 30 years i mean
you have to know for 30 years you've
been dealing with people who cheat lie
steal kill
and
and you're trying to come home and say
babe how are you oh my gosh kids daddy's
here to play with you how you doing did
you do your homework of course i did my
homework you're like you know this kid
didn't do his homework so how do you how
do you not bring your work home
with what you do on a daily basis
my kids knew
when i was on the major investigation
side my kids knew where i was by the
news because
the county is the the department we were
on was quite small so if there was a
homicide of murder
um it would make the national news
uh or the you know the local news most
certainly so my kids knew and i was
quite an errant father i see this this
is a true story my son
um plays field hockey he's six foot five
he's
he's a he's a giant now but he plays
field hockey i know that you don't play
field hockey out there guys don't play
field hockey out there and he got
through to a national final and i was in
washington dc with the at the fbi
academy um doing a job there
i should have been at home i should have
been at home i should have been watching
my son play hockey um
and
you know i'm doing it all by the phone
how'd he get on yeah he did really well
you know you just
i missed out so much but here's the
other thing of that story
i traveled out there with a single pubic
hair um a young girl been
been
sexually assaulted
and a single pubic hair was found on her
underwear
and we'd identified the suspect dna the
whole whole nine yards
but they
brought into doubt how she collected
this on her body
so we went and found a scientist that
the fbi um
in quantico we went up there
fascinating guy a guy called carrion you
you couldn't wish to meet a nicer guy
but more interesting he's he's the man
who found the um
the blood or the fibers on the on the
break of the murder victim in in
texas when they dragged the black guy
behind the truck and
he found a microscope a microscopic
piece of debris and they and they linked
that car to the murder of that guy
absolutely fascinating black anyway we
we go over there
with a single pubic hair
i wasn't allowed to fly down to my
family holiday
in florida my parents had a house in
florida at the time i had to fly all the
way back to the uk for one day
and then fly back to the states after
the kid by the way who sexually
assaulted the girl he got found not
guilty by the by the court by the jury
they couldn't decide how that hair was
found on her on the inside of her
clothing attached to her body
he said that he'd urinated in particular
place the hair had been secreted it went
onto her
inside of her clothing
blah blah blah anyway
did the kid ever commit another crime
later on in life or no he got locked up
he in fact within three days he went out
committed a robbery and he got locked up
for five years
good
um
we get on a plane flying down florida
usa into charlotte from charlotte down
to um down to temper
excuse me kids have got the fbi hats on
so this isn't long after 9 11.
yeah so that everyone's a bit twitchy
around it
guy walks up says to the kids and the
kids are about three rows back but
they're in double seats sitting on their
own
we didn't want to sit with them have
them sit with us they were a pain you
know just oh can we have this
so and the steward system where'd you
get the hatch from guys because got fbi
had said oh my dad's just been out that
day's just been out to quantico brings
over a bottle of whiskey he says we
welcome law enforcement
on usa
he's been my friend ever since
ever since wow
he still lives in charlotte and i still
keep contacting that's cool that's cool
yeah it's cool it's cool but you know
we're lucky police police guys and girls
are lucky it is a great job despite the
popular media giving them a kick in on a
regular basis some of it is deserved
some of it's not um it's still a great
job
great job it's still a great job
so you know
i would be so curious to know who was
the first person in your family that
became a cop so
um
my grandmother's uncle
left ireland went to new york and became
a flat foot up there that was in about
19 20
28 something like that
um
my
i had another uncle who joined the
police service in 1934. in fact
i've still got family in the police
today my nephew's still serving
um as a civilian member of staff for the
police service and i've still got family
in the irish place in the garda
so and it's it's been like that since
let's say at least 1934. only reason i
said is because whoever was the first
person probably sold the career as so
honorable and great that others wanted
to follow it because
you know there
there there has to be
you know sometimes i have a friend of
mine him and i joined the army together
we got out
everybody was asking me how was the army
best decision i made in my life they
asked him how is the army worst decision
i made in my life right
and that guy's kids are probably never
going to want to serve the military if
my kids want to join the military i'm
okay with it because the military really
shaped uh my life in a big way
yeah so
it's interesting hearing you say good
things about the life of being a cop
well well gladys knight i mean i'm
really into my music but she was she
said could it be that it was also very
simple then or as time rewritten every
line and if we had the chance to do it
all again tell me would we could we and
yeah i would if i started again tomorrow
i would go back and join the police
service it is the greatest job that i've
ever ever done well paul i got to tell
you i've enjoyed talking to you man this
has been really
uh uh uh insightful
disturbing at the same time with some of
the stories
uh uh
relieved to know that some folks got
justice
uh and uh grateful that some people like
yourself choose
to
get into the profession that you're in
because it's so necessary and i rest
respect the folks in your world who do
the good job do do do the right way
because the world without you would be a
very difficult world and very painful
for many people out there so having said
that thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
thank you sir it's been absolutely
brilliant to meet you and uh when i'm
down in florida i'll take you for a warm
beer somewhere i know you drink cold
beers down there come on down it's all
good come on down i'd love to entertain
you i'll host you if you're down here
you just let me know
i'll i will be there i've got friends
and
clients down there i look forward to it
same goes when you're in london i've got
some very swanky places i can take you
swanky places i'm curious to see some
swanky places yeah well i
i don't know if he's going i'm a
volunteer at the tower of london have
you been to
england i've been to england i've been
to london i don't know if i've been to
the tower of london i don't think i have
well every tuesday night um they i'm
there and they do think of the ceremony
of the keys where they lock the tower up
and they have done for the past 700
years and if you want to come i'll take
you there as well i'd love to i'd like
it's a beautiful city i have great
experience when i go there so once again
thank you so much take care of yourself
nice to see it take care bye-bye so
thoughts would you want his job would
you want to do what he does could you do
what he does some of those stories very
dark stories right do you agree with
them that some people are born evil that
was a very interesting answer that he
gave comment below if you enjoyed this
interview you may also enjoy the
interview with the detective i did who
was working on the biggie and tupac case
greg kating if you've never seen that
one before
probably one of the most interesting
interviews i've ever done because i grew
up listening to those two guys and we
had all the different potential uh
people involved in the murder and you
see how he goes about pointing at who
could have been behind a murderer big in
tupac if you've never seen that it'd be
very entertaining
click here to watch that take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]